hey lights I'm here with Abdullah
Mahmoud from all alia folding group what
can you tell us about the partnership
that all Olli group has been doing with
more whole Al Ahly Holding Group and
Marvel and Disney have been having this
partnership for the last three years and
the partnership has grown over the three
years we started this partnership with
the red carpet premiere event of
Avengers age of Ultron we followed up
last year with Captain America Civil War
and today here where their guardians of
galaxy vol 2 red carpet premiere event
we got some exciting products that we
are going to launch today oh I know I we
have some behind us right now and now
you guys also have some cool stuff
coming up maybe with us definitely as
you see the guardians of galaxy vol 2
collectibles the cubed collectibles
these products that are going to be
showcased here will also be showcased at
our pop culture of corn Comic Con events
we got our event are coming up in Manila
which is happening in August 2017 and
the event is called Asia pop comic-con
this will be followed by the buy popcorn
event so it's going to be lots of fun
for the fanboys across the world that
sounds super fun I wish I could be there
myself
now last year or a few years ago we
asked who was your favorite Guardian I
think you said who was it who was it
last time I thought it was rocket
because he had the wisecracks and he was
witty and fun but now this time new film
blank slate who's your favorite guardian
I think it's gonna be baby Groot he's
gonna be lots of fun and I'm sure he's
gonna be the small dynamite who's gonna
burn the screen wonderful let's go check
in with tomorrow right now thank you so
much thank you